in the movie godzilla vs com
there were two gigantic monsters that
appeared in the apex facility
in hong kong and yes they were the
mechanized titan mechagodzilla and a
hyper carnivorous
red skull crawler of course we saw them
both in action
well more like an execution but they
were active nonetheless
so in this video we will assess them
both and come up with a credible size
estimate
for both monsters but before we go
deeper into this video
do remember to hit that subscribe button
to be a part of the mind cue family
so let's get down with this sickness
first of all in order to get their sizes
we have to get something to reference
them against
and let's see the two times whose sizes
were officially stated for the movie
we have kong who was around 356 feet
tall
or 108.5 meters who has grown more than
three times his height from this first
appearance in golden skull island
next we have the king of the monsters
godzilla who was 355 feet tall in 2014
and then went up to 393 feet tall for
both king of the monsters and godzilla
vs com
which is almost 120 meters if converted
to the metric system
well we shall use them both as reference
points to estimate mechagodzilla's
height
and then the skull crawler against mecca
later on
in the wake of ghidorah's catastrophic
rampage in 2019 the technology
conglomerate apex cybernetics developed
mechagodzilla
the completed mechagodzilla's power was
measured against an adult skull crawler
in an enclosed
apex facility in hong kong with the
mecca's power and energy
beam slicing through the titan slicing
in half
although it is kind of curious that apex
had the capabilities
to grow their own skull crawlers in
captivity since they are powerful
bloodlust titans
the mecca was seen underground and was
curled up like a bowl
and then gradually stood up and the
reveal was one of the most epic ones for
the monsterverse
force folding a little bit in hong kong
the mecca battle and completely
dominated against
godzilla and even when kong came into
the fight and teamed up with the big g
mechagodzilla still overpowered both
godzilla and kong
while being pitted against each other
however before mechagodzilla could stop
and kill kong with his tail
josh valentine poured alcohol onto the
control panel
causing it to stall for a brief moment
allowing godzilla to charge corm's axe
then kong uses his axe to dismember and
decapitate mecha godzilla
effectively ending his reign of terror a
brief reign of terror
here in this battle of hong kong we can
clearly see the size differences between
the three tyrants comb could literally
ride the robot like a cowboy on a large
bull
here in these scenes we can see that
godzilla was shorter than the mecca
and during the beam duel scene his head
was seen only at the maker's chest but
then again
he could have been standing on lower
ground so let's
look at another scene the one where both
corm and godzilla teamed up
and rammed the mecca through a building
these two talents got a hold of
mechagodzilla's arms and you can clearly
see that it was
at least a head taller than godzilla and
kong would only be around his chest and
height
comb could even climb up like a monkey
on a mango tree and on the scene you can
clearly see that the mecha's arm
was almost as long as gong's height
maybe a bit shorter
so by our best estimate mechagodzilla
would have been around 450 to 460 feet
tall around 100 feet taller than
kong and more than 60 feet taller than
godzilla so yeah
mecca g is between 450 to 460 feet tall
so with the mechagodzilla's size
complete he is now the second biggest
island in the monster verse after
monster zero
let's not get into the longest as that
would be the snake titans warbat and
titanos tiamat and maybe even godzilla
anyway we still have the skull quality
estimate back in skull island the big
one was twice as long as kong was tall
which puts it around 200 feet long so
during the brutal
execution scene in the sacrificial pit
mechagodzilla stood up straight and
grabbed the skullcrawler by its limbs
and then proceeded to stretch it
outwards the skullcrawler's
size is seen to be apparently a bit
longer than mechagodzilla's height
which would therefore put it around 500
feet long
and therefore by comparing with corm of
1973 and a big one
we would get its height at somewhere
between 150 to 180 feet tall
so putting them all in one picture we
would get this
the skull crawler would be dwarfed by
the three main titans of the movie
and would even be smaller than warbat or
nuzuki
maybe bigger than the hollow earth
lizard which is not manila
or godzilla junior and i can assure you
why
in the next video so like for support
and hit that subscribe button to be a
part of the minecube family
and also smash that notification bell
for regular updates on new
monsterverse content godzilla vs context
section videos
gvk kingdom com and godzilla dominion
topics as well
take care fam